um i've made very bad decisions with my
health i've done drugs i've smoked i've
drank i've eaten
very bad food very good food um
but you go around the country and you
look at some people some people dude
i mean it's bad it's truly bad the level
of
you know decay it's bad
the the fat is wild i mean there's a lot
of people that are just way over four
four or five yeah oh yeah big
the skin you see on some people's is not
good
years of environmental factors maybe
maybe it's drugs maybe it's booze but
you look around at people and sometimes
you just look at people
and you feel guilty a little bit because
you have a good life you have a decent
life i have a decent life
it's pretty good and sometimes i look at
somebody at a rest stop they're like
sunken in eyes
and i can tell they're they you know
they were probably raised in a in a coal
mine
by two parents that just beat and [ __ ]
them or something and like
this person is just they have these
sunken in eyes
and they're just doing the best they can
um
and like i'm like hey man you have any
yogurts
and they're like you know no
and i feel so bad for them
that i will only i feel like so
bad for them that i will only scream at
them for two or three minutes
like i will not usually i'll scream at
someone for like a solid
six minutes i will genuinely only scream
at these people
for two or three minutes because they've
had it so bad
you know and i go hey what the [ __ ] is
going on here
am i wow i mean the hills have eyes
stills have eyes out there i mean this
country
large swaths of the country are full of
people
who the the horror movie you could just
make a documentary
you could just pull into like any strip
mall and just make a documentary
just put sad music hi my name is fern
like just you got a doc you got a doc
everything well documentaries are hard
no they're not
in this country and not at all go to a
rest stop you got a documentary
i could make a brilliant rest stop
documentary tomorrow
it's [ __ ] easy these documentary
filmmakers just point a [ __ ] picture
it's uh they point their camera to
[ __ ]
and let them talk for an hour and then
they get a [ __ ]
golden globe and academy award oh it's
so hard to make it that no it's not
it is not just point your go to a
bowling alley
in alabama you have a documentary now
find somebody who's worked there for 30
years
and just ask them about their life you
just hear the bowls
the pins you know and then you have just
somebody
just eating nacho cheese with the one
finger they have left because they lost
the other ones in the [ __ ] ball
retrieval
everyone's a brilliant documentary i
mean there's this documentary darwin
which is a good documentary they just
found the smallest town in the america
in death valley california it's a great
documentary they did a documentary
called october country beautiful
cinematic gorgeous they just went to a
family upstate that's all [ __ ] up
that's any family
hello you're in a documentary now tell
us about your lives
are you [ __ ] two i'm gonna go win an
award
the guy did it donnell mosher i think
he's a photographer he did it about his
own family
but i will say this i loved october
country
i thought it was brilliant
i think it's called yes i thought it was
brilliant
and then he never did anything else
which upset me and i actually also like
darwin
i just want to let these people know
that artistically i know what you're
doing it's nowhere near
as difficult as what i do every week
which is yell about things that bother
me
with no preparation into uh a camera
that i don't even know how to set up
you understand so artistically i just
want you to know that i see you
it's called october country right it is
it's just a tragedy but it's great man
upstate
is just tragic it's great but when you
get upstate you just want to take a pill
when you go upstate new york
knowing that down state is just thriving
metropolis or was
thanks de blasio um de blasio's
daughter's like running around shooting
cops
now you know really she was arrested for
like looting de blasio's daughter
his people are i mean god so
knowing that the down state of new york
is like a thriving metropolis
it makes upstate even sadder because
there's some natural beauty upstate
but there are these old factory towns
where all the factories have left i mean
i was just
i got locked out of my chase account and
i just spent an hour on the phone
with people in india and god love them
and listen
they're trying to better their lives no
hatred towards them but all of these
[ __ ] jobs customer service
um you know manufacturing a lot of them
went
overseas with nafta and all those people
in new york state were just left to die
they were just left to to die there and
when you go to these towns you just want
to take a perk-a-doodle-doo
you want to take a a a percocet
my aunt used to get really [ __ ] up on
pills and we came up with a song me and
my cousins
came up with a song where we would just
go perka doodle doo
[Music]
perka doodle don't
we'll perk a doodle will
i bet you perka doodle won't because she
used to just sit in the chair
uh all pilled out and all drunk now she
just goes on the book
but it goes on the face book
but i'll i'll tell you right now i get
this documentary canard i'm unimpressed
by it
i've been i've been out on the road for
two weeks i've been in nine
documentaries
every store is a documentary things are
not great